What's up guys!
We are Pongfinity.
So we have hit 600 000 subscribers
which is really amazing
because we only hit 500K
less than month ago.
For this special episode
We are playing a wrong hand
tournament.
Let's find out who wins!
It's going to be me!
Guess the hand.
I will start.
Love all, please play!
Oh no!
My forehand technique is beautiful!
Miikka doesn't have a backhand!
I just don't need it.
I'm playing forehand all table.
One - one.
That wasn't even close!
Great placement!
Even better than with the left hand!
Three - two.
Oh no!
There!
That was a good one.
That was a horrible serve.
That was my special serve!
I'm not gonna use it again.
Are you laughing at my technique?
No, no! It looks really good!
Thanks!
I'm just not very good, am I?
You are good but Otto is just better.
Oh no!
This is embarrassingly bad!
Nine - four.
You push the bat like this!
A great backhand to follow up!
Eleven - four to Otto!
Great match!
Do you want to start?
I will let you start.
I feel like I can beat anybody!
Was that a push or a topspin?
I don't know what you what you call that!
Down.
I think it touched!
Up!
It was your own side.
You are supposed to hit over the net.
Good serve!
This is going to be a tight match.
No! No backhands!
Don't play backhands.
It touched the table!
Really good save! The forehand.
I could have taken it with my backhand but no I used forehand.
How were you taking it?
There!
That's a good tactic.
That's the combo!
Oh no!
You are just standing there!
It's eight - eight!
It's getting close!
How can I miss that?
Nine - eight.
No!
That was probably the biggest point of my life!
That was a good rally.
Yes!
You need a break after that one!
Play!
Sorry.
And he gets it with the serve!
No!
Thanks!
Thank you.
Zero - zero. Emil to serve.
I have no other option
than to beat Otto.
It's not the easiest obstacle.
Sorry!
Lucky.
Not bad actually.
Good placement!
There was a big forehand coming.
That's the big forehand I was talking about.
Otto doesn't even look like he is playing with his wrong hand.
I will give you a point for that.
Sorry!
It was the edge.
That was so difficult.
A high one to the backhand.
Five - one.
Nothing is going in anymore!
Otto is looking strong.
How can I miss that?
Six - four.
Look at that!
What a tactic!
Six - six.
Good comeback.
No!
Seven - seven.
Almost!
Good swing on that!
What a return!
You got arrogant after the one good shot.
I always do.
So close!
Almost.
Nice!
I have to get a nice finish.
So close!
I think it might have even touched.
Let's check the replay.
The ball was out.
We checked it a few times. The ball was out.
Point to Emil.
Almost!
Oh no!
I missed it!
Now I am playing safe.
He just doesn't want to win it!
Now is my best serve coming.
Oh no!
Good fight!
Let us know in the comments
what kind of tournament you want to see next.
Also hit subscribe
and check out our
previous videos there.
Until next time!